الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث اعلن وزير
الدفاع الروسي ان الفرقاطه لذا الروسيه
الادميرال جروسكووف ستبحر الى المحيط
الاطلسي والهندي والبحر المتوسط واضاف
الوزير الروسي ان الفرقه ستجرى خلال
ابحارها تدريبات باستخدام صواريخ فرط
الصوتيه وتعليقا على الخبر قال الرئيس
الروسي فلاديفر بوتين ان بدا عمل الفرقاطه
الروسيه الادميرال جرشكو حدث هام واضاف
قتل ان الاسلحه القويه تحملها الفرقاطه
الروسيه تحمي روسيا من التهديدات الخارجيه
هذا هو اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن
ارتفاع عدد القتلى من العسكريين الروس
نتيجه قصف مركز تابع للجيش في مدينه
الى 89 قتيلا وقال نائب رئيس الاداره
العسكريه في الجيش الروسي ان تحقيقات
الاوليه تشير الى ان استخدام الجنود
للهواتف المحموله كان سببا في كشف موقعهم
الاول
ضربه بسته صواريخ من طراز هاي مارس لنقطه
انتشار مؤقته لاحدى الوحدات العسكريه
بالقرب من بلده تم اعتراض صاروخين بينما
اصابه اربعه منها المبنى الذي كان يتمركز
فيه العسكريون الروس لسوء الحظ اثناء رفع
الانقاذ ارتفع عدد رفاقنا الذين لقوا
حتفهم الى 99 وكان من بين القتلى نائب
قائد الفوج المقدم
تم تدميره راجيمته هاي مارس التي اطلقت
منها الصواريخ وحاليا تعمل لجنه لتحقيق في
الملابسات الحادث لكن من الواضح ان السبب
الرئيسي هو الاستخدام المكثف للهواتف
المحموله وذلك خلافا للتعليمات وهو ما سمح
للعدو بتحديد احداثيات الموقع
متابعه الوضع معانا من ديني برومو مراسيل
الجزيره عمر الحاج ومن موسكو مراسله
الجزيره رانيا دريد وابدا معك رانيا بخبر
الفرقه الادميرال جروب التي تم الاعلان عن
مهمتها في المحيط الاطلسي والهندي وكذلك
في البحر المتوسط وتحليق الرئيس الروسي
على مهمه هذه الفرقه
في الخدمه هو حدث مهم هكذا وصف الرئيس
الفيديو في هذه المراسم يعني اعرب الرئيس
الروسي عبد القادر عن ثقته بان دخول هذه
الفرقه للخدمه هذه الفرقات المزوده
بالصواريخ فرض صوتيه من تراث سيركون هي
قادره وتسمح بحمايه امن روسيا همم حسب
تعبير بوتن واعربه عن ثقته بقدرات هذه
الفرقات من جهته ايضا اشاره وزير الدفاع
الروسيه الذي ايضا شارك في هذه المراسم
همم بان هذه
الفرقات قادره على التغلب على كل انظمه
الدفاع الجوي على كل الانظمه الصاروخيه
الحديثه والمستقبليه خلال عملياتها
العسكريه اشاره لانها ستتوجه الى المحيطين
الهندي والاطلسي وايضا الى البحر الابيض
المتوسط خلال هذه الرحله التي همم تقول
السلطات الروسيه انها ستقول ستكون طويله
الامد ستقوم هذه الفرقات بتنفيذ تدريبات
عسكريه بما في ذلك باستخدام صواريخ سيركون
اود الاشاره وتذكير بان هذه الصواريخ تبلغ
سرعتها
وهي تفوق سرعه الصوف بالاضافه الى ذلك هذه
الفرقات او هذه الصواريخ قادره ليس فقط
على ضرب الاهداف البحريه وايضا قادره على
ضرب الاهداف البحريه اذا يمكن القول عبد
القادر همم يعني دخول هذه الفرقاده حيز
الخدمه في هذه المرحله الحساسه في ظل كل
التهديدات التي تتحدث عنها روسيا والصادره
بالدراجات الاولى عن احلفي شمال الاطلسي
وعلى راسه الولايات المتحده بالفعل لها
اشارات هي رسائل موجهه
لهذه الدول على راسها الولايات المتحده ان
روسيا تم من القدرات ما يكفي لضمان امنها
وامني اراضيها وهنا ود التذكير بان شيقو
اشار الى ان هذه الفرقاطه اا ستعمل الى
جانب الدول الدول الصديقه حسب وصفه على
ضمان الامن والاستقرار الدوليه